Charlie: Oh.
No.
Not so much.
I was thinking… this is like too much.
Leah: Too much draping?
Charlie: Mhmm.
Leah: Yeah, I think we can’t do that.
Charlie: Yeah, and I just wonder about a heavier
weight fabric so that it could hang but not
drape at the same time.
Like canvas or something.
Mack: This hangs pretty well.
Charlie: I know.
But it doesn’t do anything.
I mean, it might as well be tight if you’re
doing that.
I don’t know…
Aaron: You’re looking for some texture.
Charlie: Maybe what I’m imagining doesn’t
exist in reality.
I don’t know.
I mean, the more I’ve thought about it I
think that just a simple…
Leah: …hanging but stiffer cloth?
Charlie: Hanging… a non-stretched cloth
that’s not… doesn’t look like it’s
supposed to be stretched.
That’s sort of a tall order, I don’t know…
Leah: Yeah, I kind of have a vision of that
too.
Like a tarp, with grommets almost?
That you can imagine that you would suspend
with the grommets and it would feel like heavy?
Mack: Then we could hang it off the wall,
or we could hang it off the ceiling.
Leah: Yeah.
Charlie: Yeah, I mean so the issue is really
what should the scale be relative to the other
works, and then what…
I was thinking that the image would be smaller
than this in relation…
I don’t know.
Originally I thought it was kind of going
to be small, but maybe that’s wrong.
Leah: I think we should use space here.
Partly because we’re going to have a bench
here.
It’s captivating.
The scale of the gull piece is big here.
I don’t think it should be small.
Charlie: The minute you put a moving image
up, you know, you want to give a lot of space
to the other things.
Leah: I think that’s okay.
Charlie: No, I think it’s fine too.
I just don’t want to…
Leah: I know what you’re doing.
You’re being respectful.
But I think this feels good as you’re walking
in.
And then if there’s a bench you’ll sit
there.
Charlie: And then the Brazos River is over
here?
Leah: Brazos Rivers is actually in this corner
here.
Is this the monitor you’re planning on using?
Mack: Well that’s one.
We have another.
Leah: I wonder if that feels like it’s maybe
one notch too big for that wall?
What do you think?
I mean, I can live with it if you think it’s
right.
Mack: What’s the smaller option?
Like twenty inches?
Aaron: The smaller is like nineteen inches,
yes.
Leah: A lot smaller.
Charlie: That would be too small.
Leah: Yeah, okay.
Stick with it then.
Mack: What we can look at…
We can’t embed, but we can build something
white, you know we can make like a white fascia
for it that will cover it.
Charlie: Instead of the black?
That’s what we talked about.
Mack: Because I think part of why it’s so
big is all of that.
And if that were white it would feel…
Leah: It would feel a little less big on the
wall.
Mack: A little less giant…
And you want to be able to see it.
Again, the bench is going to be kind of in
the middle…